protests have broken out in cuba with
thousands of people taking to the
streets against the communist government
demonstrators expressed frustration at
food shortages
rising prices and the lack of covert
vaccines the government blames the u.s
for the unrest and is rallying its own
supporters
[Applause]
they are crying out for freedom in the
streets of havana
this the greatest show of discontent
with the socialist government
since the 1990s like back then
the trigger for this protest is the
desperate economic situation
right now the country is suffering from
food shortages
we're here because of the repression of
the people they are starving us to death
havana is collapsing we have no homes
nothing
soon the police arrive and they begin to
drag off people in the crowd
the arrests and the violence only make
the demonstrators angrier
we're not afraid they cry out
security beat me and my daughter a child
they beat us just because we were
walking down the street
supporters of the government have been
out in the streets too
president miguel diaz canal himself led
this rally
he was organized quickly in a town
outside havana
where the anti-government protest began
early on sunday
we came here to show together with the
revolutionaries here that the streets
belong to us
with the president encouraging
supporters to mobilize against opponents
there were ugly confrontations here
revolutionaries detained opposition
protesters
the cubans who are here we are never
going to give up this revolution never
a communist regime has ruled cuba since
1959
it survived the fall of the soviet union
and the death of its founder fidel
castro
now it is again being challenged
but displays like these show it is
unlikely to go without a fight
ted henkin is an associate professor at
the city university of new york
specializing in cuba
and he joins me now ted thanks for your
time scenes like this are pretty rare
in cuba who's behind these protests
well i think it's fairly obvious that
the people are behind it
this is a protest that has no leader
has no organization that may be a
weakness of it
going forward but it seems to have
broken
through because the accumulated
frustration
over the past two one or two years
with the economic crisis food shortages
medical
shortages caused primarily by the
economic system of cuba that's
inefficient and unproductive
and on top of that of course you have
the u.s embargo that isolates or
attempts to isolate
and cut cuba off i think the people are
caught in the middle and they're fed up
with excuses with lies with manipulation
the government claims that this is
orchestrated paid by the united states
how do you get people in six or eight
cities all across
cuba thousands of people in each case to
protest
from the united states it's ridiculous
to claim that
at the same time we don't know really
what the next step is how the government
is responding now
it seems to be inflaming the protesters
and not leading to any kind of
negotiated solution
could this be the start do you think of
a major opposition movement against the
communist regime
well i would say that it's a
continuation back in november of 2000
you had
the beginnings of an unprecedented uh
coming together of
artists intellectuals who had
mostly kept quiet kept their heads down
so they could keep their jobs and their
positions
and they came out in the street at the
end of november
to protest and that was scuttled
but it has kind of gone underground and
has built up
a following that led to uh
the the the chant and the song
patria evita homeland and life
that was directly aimed at the
government's
claim of either you choose the homeland
or
death that was a very popular song
and that was the thing that many of the
protesters were chanting so this seems
to be
a continuation of that but it's been
triggered by the scarcity of medicines
and the spike the sudden and deadly
spike
and covet cases and covert deaths in
various parts of the country
right all right cuba expert ted henkin
thanks very much for your analysis
thank you